Not only was Ron desantis's Twitter
spaces campaign launch a complete and
total humiliation his campaign website
just looks terrible it looks like it was
designed in the 1990s it something is
just very wrong with every aspect of Ron
desantis's campaign and one of the funny
things about the santis is he's in his
early 40s and when you look at him you
you I think this guy's got to be 55 or
closer to 60. he's in his early 40s but
in so many different ways he seems to
have absolutely no connection to the
sort of contemporary social and cultural
norms of people his age and the website
very much fits with that is anybody
going to help this guy make his campaign
something other than a complete and
total humiliation or is this the way
it's going to be all the way to what
will almost certainly be a very pathetic
end let me know what you think in the
comments does this campaign have legs or
is it just going to remain this pathetic
forever